dr. ranson about president Trump's
behavior actor Robert De Niro's now in
big legal trouble over his own conduct a
former assistant slapping the actor with
a 12 million dollar lawsuit for abusive
and sexist comments this ex would have
filled voicemail is at the center of
that Goodfellas 1 what was that a real
now you can't even tell the difference
yeah you know I think it's offensive
behavior and certainly an offensive they
reminded me that call between Alec
Baldwin his daughter is even worse right
but I think look I suspect that you guys
are doing this because he's anti Trump I
think that's what's going dare you
because I feel very I'm outraged by did
you here's what you should be outraged
by imagine somebody suing because they
have a rude offensive bomb
a little more serious and being written
offensive but he sued her I guess before
she could sue him well they here's the
outrageous thing she binge-watched 50
episodes of friends while at work I'm
sorry but you deserve to be sued no but
you know I you know I do think that like
she worked with him for ten years yeah
and it's just it just seems like a
cashing in kind of thing as much as I
would like to crap all over to Nero
because he's been he's a hypocrite he
uses terrible language and he's yelling
at Trump he never has a reason for Trump
anymore just yells about it but I don't
know Dana
well it is shocking to hear it and that
I go back to I've been working for a
long time I've never been in this
situation where you had a boss that was
saying things like that he was like
never happened to I've heard your
assistant talk about you oh my god all
right not even during the Iraq war not
is not a peak area okay no yelling I'm
with Greg you know ten years later these
lawsuits always bring out a little more
information that's in the news reporting
that's being pushed by the lawyers from
both sides so I'm just gonna take a step
back and be the bigger person and
although Robert De Niro has some
thoughts about us at Fox News I'm not
going to repay the favor and I'll say
good luck and good luck to both sides
not gonna take a side and you can fight
it out in court and good luck you know I
think that hug must have had an impact
we're all yes you got to be nice because
you know he does oh no boo I went there
twice dumplings are delicious had a good
table I'm going back this weekend